[Musique]
quelqu'un c'était me tuer je m'appelle
miles et voici l'histoire de la pire
journée de ma vie
nouvelle attaque de spin off qui ce
qu'ils aiment choisissez au hasard des
psychopathes des tarés ou des criminels
et les obliger à s'affronter jusqu'à la
mort alors ça faisait bande est
interdite jusqu'à ce que j'entre dans la
partie alors tu as peur ça y est
son fils et ses trucs sur mes mains
ils ont ma copine
les psychopathes et c'est le but
arrête de tirer clé
il faut que je te tue fils brady qui
dépasserait mon ardoise qui fait on va
nous tuer tous les plans j'ai un plan
c'est carrément suicidaire
j'ai gagné
[Musique]
ouah
[Applaudissements]
non non ça
oui
ok
6 2
[Musique]
oh
le stack
[Musique]
g tous ces jeunes témoins
urb l'avs
je répèterai des cieux clap costello
derrière cette image nous
[Musique]
tom qu'est-ce qui se passe candiac est
kidnappée et toi tu viens de tirer sur
la seule piste qu'on avait sur eux la
pluie du siaap folk je dois vous avertir
que vous êtes diffusé à des millions de
personnes à travers le monde en ce
moment pourquoi tout journaliste tu
arrêter de fumer
tu as raison quelqu'un a pris la fille
de vol qu elle est dans une fois
quelques paris elle va s'y noyer je peux
pas rester à rien faire
il ya parfois des gens qui meurent tout
le monde s'en fout tu vas voir je dois
continuer maintenant on doit continuer
le travail et pas de rond tu as failli
mourir en essayant de sauver ton ski
puisque défaut d'adhésion
règles de base tu me laisse travailler
et tu parles seulement quand je te le
demande mais je veux filmer tout ce qui
se passe
têtu et mon frère
diffuse en direct
circuit
oui ce qu'elle est vrai pour moi
on a plus de temps à perdre
[Musique]
sarah collonges scène d'horreur dans la
banlieue de damas et pourrait s'agir
d'un empoisonnement par 700 chimiques
les syriens sont prêts à payer des
millions pour développer leur arsenal
chimique
cette femme est notre meilleure piste
depuis des années
alors vous avez un plan
ils sont besoin d'elle donc il faut
qu'elle ait besoin de moi
illimitée avant que ces armes chimiques
ne tombent entre de mauvaises mains
il faut construire d'ici l'arrivée
les cônes recherchons sur ben spies
euros je pense pouvoir aider votre
organisation elle va mordre à l'hameçon
et si elle meurt pas
il ya beaucoup de gens qui feront tout
pour m'empêcher de dévoiler la vérité
tu nous a menti
vous ne pouvez pas rester ici on n'y
vais plus faire marche arrière sur evra
je sais très bien ce que je fais
c'est moi qui était poussé à le faire
quitter mon ordi je suis fini
c'était près de chéri alors on y va
vous avez vu ça vous voyez comme elle me
fait confiance et ils seraient prêtes à
mourir pour moi français
carline je peux vous parler j'aimerais
que vous alliez voir les filles manson
comme la peine de mort a été abolie on
ne sait plus quoi en faire
elles vont rester enfermés là l'une à
côté de l'autre 23 heures sur 24 vous
emmène oisel je vous présente car une
faillite elle donne des cours à
certaines détenus d'ici le seul livre
que charlie voulait bien qu'on essaie la
bible alors est ce que ça veut dire que
vous avez l'impression de faire quelque
chose de mal en étudiant avec moi ça me
rangerai bien d'étudier comment vivaient
les femmes de pionnier c'est ce qu'on
apprenait avec janot
avec du travail de la terre ne suffisant
c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire tu vois
c'est de se débarrasser de nos
inhibitions poursuivre au maximum
quand vous autres cycliques et les
magnifiques elles peuvent pas se libérer
son ego ça fait trois ans qu'elle n'ont
plus vu elle pas que de lui lui les
conneries qu'il a pu leur mettre dans la
tête
on va attendre sous la terre on pourra
jouer de la musique et faire l'amour en
attendant la fin de la guerre
charles et disait la vérité l'apocalypse
arrive notre monde et voilà disparaître
la clé de tout ça c'est quand ce secteur
c'est pouvoir qu'une porte dessus d'un
lac heures rascal totale là-dessus
jamais dit mais toi qu'est ce que tu en
penses
ce n'était jamais arrivé de te dire que
peut-être elle tord sculptera les jeunes
et descendre que charlize trompé il ya
des femmes dans cette prison qui sont
réellement des victimes et peut-être que
celle là aussi c'est en définitive que
dirait pareil si c'était ta soeur
enceinte poignardé de 20 coups de
couteau c'est qu'ils peuvent si je
parviens à leur faire voir réellement
face ce credo faire
ils seront forcés de vivre advitam avec
serveur c'est bien le but de la prison
avant
efi pourquoi vous avez fait ça il nous a
dit protester charlie est venu nous
parler cette nuit
[Musique]
bordel vous êtes en garde à vue pour
trafic de stupéfiants en thérapie âge et
sa baby chinatown moral
un petit hôtel j'aime passer le chambre
c'est pas un hôtel ici c'est un ehpad et
ça me coûte 3200 euros par mois à table
et pas d'abolition des femmes viennent
galerie locale mathis marc clémeur accra
destouches à philippe sonnet met aux
prises deux autoroutes mais mika trois
camions khadija y avait combien dans ce
camion a les dents - n'est pas partir
furet billets de banque et drogue est
mignon celui-là il oublie de monsieur et
chercheurs
[Musique]
booth arrivages blade devant un demi
mètre de frappe à 250 watts boujenah
frères lac à l'errance lé finir à la
galère en salle et finit 1 à madame
barkat
il y à date marque nvc la lituanie
mabri chra blé times et à will meet in
et moi tout si vous êtes des crevards il
ya une femme qui dit il détonne de shit
dans paris on est un cave de la choper
sur la tête de ma mère c'est l'impact de
ses patins ça fait toujours plaisir un
client mécontent du produit c'est
pourquoi ces technocrates et parce que
ce chiffre que tu dors dans il était
vraiment quelque chose de paradoxal
c'est un jour tu dégages de confiance en
toi ça m'impressionnait
tu peux penser à des mecs que j'ai deux
coffrets oui on dit comment un gros
doigt dans le fion en armes ce bac bière
faisceau il y a quelque chose de
dangereux dans l'ennui des adolescentes
la coach avait vu quelque chose en nous
au delà des paillettes des cheveux et de
notre attitude
elle avait vu ce qui se cachait dessous
[Musique]
une nouvelle coach débarque en ville et
elle s'imagine qu'elle peut diriger mon
équipe
oui il avait l'air tellement seul au
point que tu risquerais te faire mal
même ça
vous devriez vous méfier de baisse
[Musique]
m
si tu veux mon avis il ya quelque chose
qui tourne pas rond chez 7,9
tu volé quoi que je la laisse tomber
aujourd'hui vous êtes terrell dbs
faites-les s'incliner devant tout ce
qu'on fait on le fait avec intensité
désir fougue
[Musique]
en fin de compte
je ne pouvais rien empêché
je suis
[Musique]
ah oui
donc maintenant
on en rêvait en charge
voir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cliquez ici
[Musique]
médina
même pas peur